[Music]
happy
birthday alex thank you thank you for
coming
yeah i haven't talked to people in a
long time so it's
weird
[Music]
yep
foreign
[Music]
jenna just said that she feels like
we're on a field trip and there's no
adult but i think that i might be the
eldest in the group
so i think that i might be uh it
terrifies me that we're all adults
yeah but like i don't feel i feel like
we need another like
mom's got the tick-tock hat on can you
just show them my look
what is this i got stuff in my pocket
so there's a bee infestation here on the
island and i
don't know what to do with this
information except relay it to you
i got i got a salad um
so vlogging is so
[Music]
i used to do it a lot now i don't know
how
i'm smiling being good
is so weird and social distance i've
never been here
actually i haven't left the house very
much at all the past couple of months
but we're gonna which what
oh okay
seat belts i don't know if this is ever
going to be posted anywhere
all right let's do it well hey it's your
preference so fact that we're on
justine's golf
cart double seat belt everybody double
seat belt honestly
double secret stuff
[Music]
all right we're gonna stop here in the
middle of the road
he knows
i'm not as fast okay you can get back in
now
we were testing to see if you could you
won race faster than the
car dude i told you no you you basically
kept up no i didn't yes you did
i lost see if you could run as fast and
you did it for how long
like that yeah congratulations
look i appreciate you lifting me up but
i lost
uh yeah i kept up for like two seconds
but i can't keep my endurance up for six
seconds so
there's no way i was gonna beat you at
full speed sounds like a personal
problem
i don't know about my speed
[Music]
steam remember that one break that or
the one stop sign where you came in
super hot i honestly the brakes didn't
work
the brakes do not work well you need to
stop like a hundred yards not out of
here i almost hit like twenty feet
before
you actually i mean i like i was this
close
[Applause]
[Music]
real quick because that this is jenna's
camera i just forgot to end my video so
this is it
this is the end of the video bye happy
birthday alex thanks
i had a lovely time today me too we left
the house and did something for fun